spits nos is a Russian term typically
associated with special units of Russia
but other post-soviet states often refer
to these special forces units by the
term as well such as Ukraine and
Kazakhstan historically the name
referred to special operations units
controlled by the primary Military
Intelligence Service
however it also described other task
forces including the Ministry of
Internal Affairs and the Ministry of
Emergency Situations special rescue unit
russian special forces wear different
berets depending on the branch of Armed
Forces they belong to these include
ground forces and airborne troops
Russian Navy and Russian Marines and
National Guard because historically the
turn spit snares referred to not just
special-purpose military units it can be
a little tricky to date back to where
they first started in 1886 the Imperial
Russian army had hunter commando units
who saw combat in World War one prior to
the Russian Revolution in 1917 the Spitz
nails were also involved in the Second
World War and the Soviet war in
Afghanistan in 1979 along with tens of
thousands of special operations and
hostage situations including the Boutros
hospital hostage crisis in 1995 and the
vessel and school siege in 2004 it
wasn't until the late 1980s that the
Soviet people were given access to many
of the state secrets on the country's
special forces unit this is due to mini
Russian state secrets being disclosed
under the glass nost or openness policy
since then stories about the spit snares
and their incredible expertise has
captivated the imagination and hearts of
many patriotic Russians although some of
the tactics may be highly questionable
at times they've brought a lot of her
particularly in the midst of the
post-soviet era decay in military and
security forces in 2015 to assist in the
fight against terrorism on a global
scale five commanders were recruited by
team rainbow
these operators were to chunker capcom
fuse glass and finger
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
Aleksandra sin Aviv codenamed
tachanka is a defining operator and team
rainbow
at the age of eighteen tachanka was
recruited for military service this was
around the same time that the Soviet
Union was ending its operations in
Afghanistan following the nullification
of his draft he opted to enlist
full-time tachanka was part of the
wrestling league and is well known for
his skills in match strategy and his
powerful physique which both earned him
high distinction among others along with
heavy artillery to chunk his training
also focused on defensive and breaching
tactics and while there he also studied
as a precision tool and dye machinist
within the weapons division early in his
career the junker applied for a transfer
to the Russian Navy but for classified
reasons remained in the Armed Forces
later on he transferred to the spit snus
which was shortly before the collapse of
the Soviet Union in his personal life he
went on to marry and have children sadly
though this relationship later ended in
divorce Carmen a crisis to Juncker has a
boisterous sense of humor and a booming
laugh he can be quite blunt but
certainly without the intent to offend
he is dedicated to his team and is
focused and calm during operations there
are a number of specialists who
passionately support him yet to chunka
feels that his potential that he doesn't
know how to maximize
if javis younger sister was a doctor in
a brought up in conversation he'll
quickly bring out photos of her in a
doctor smock along with dozens more
photos of his nieces and nephews and
even his own kids
Ian's assistant grew up in a strict
household without many things which is
why it makes great effort to enjoy life
they both make sure that the kids are
loved and raised with laughter at the
same time he doesn't like to buy or
accumulate physical objects and
emphasizes this with his children motor
junker is dedicated to his country and
appreciates the life his patriotism has
brought him his Edda meant that his son
and nephew not make a career out of the
military
tachanka feels that his family and
friends should find a role where they
feel useful but not necessarily be shot
at during operations he deploys a
signature vented mounted machine gun
that he is restored and maintained with
loving care a collector of antique
weapons tachanka prefers to use original
parts rather than modern variants from
Somalia Libya and Syria to maintain as
RP 46 he utilizes the international
collector's market for replacements or
will make his own components when parts
cannot be located or are not
cost-effective to acquire
these soldiers think that training will
keep them alive they break down doors
and come through windows weapons drawn
but it still might
they forgot this first to learn the real
hunter always watches where these steps
maxim a sudha codenamed Cathcart is a
defending operator and team rainbow the
eldest of three brothers Kafka was
surrounded by the influence of the
Russian military both parents worked in
military support factories his father
and mechanical engineering and his
mother and textiles hoping to escape the
grueling life in the factory Capcom was
encouraged by his parents and teachers
to enlist in the Ministry of Internal
Affairs along with the standard training
of weapon authorities protection detail
and high-speed pursuit cop-con showed
skills with hostage rescue and
information gathering cleavers
strategies and self-sufficiency mean
that Capcom was perfect for an
undercover operation in the port town of
Nadia ma on the barren sea
his successful efforts to shut down
organized crime prompted his recruitment
into the highly respected Spitz nose
Capcom became an avid hunter and trapper
during his time in the Arctic Circle
before being transferred to be slant in
2002 Capcom was a self-sufficient
realist he has seen the harsh reality of
the world and does not allow that to
hunter his ability to act he is
fascinated by psychology what allows one
creature to become the hunter and the
other the prey on first impression
Capcom could come across as jaded about
the world and is Roland often those who
are most frustrated sound as though they
don't care when in fact they care a
great deal
it's important to Capcom that he's able
to make a lasting contribution and so
despite his cynicism he's taken it upon
himself to mentor other soldiers even
though some of the team funnyman tints
they'll speak very highly of them
kapkan enjoys a number of hobbies
centered around weapons and hunting as a
hunter he enjoys the need to think
strategically to understand the animals
routines and behaviors but it's also
imperative that the hunter respect their
prey any true hunter respects animals
they understand conservation and the
need to maintain a balance cop-con
thinks that by understanding them and
makes them a better operator because it
can apply it to people to both in how
they like animals but also in how
they're not the cap card life is harsh
made Harsha by humans decisive action
and little headedness are what matter
cup Khan is a very efficient trapper
being capable of placing as traps inside
doorways and windows which we designated
by enemies going through them the EDD
mark2 can be mounted onto windows and
door frames it explodes when enemies
into trapped entry ways projecting
shrapnel at anyone located in the blast
radius this lightweight mine design
comes with a long screw to embed the
device in the door and window frames the
EDD mark 2 utilizes a pack c4 charge to
propel an assortment of screws held in
stasis by a cell compared
shruts kazakh buyeth codenamed fuse is
an attacking operator in team rainbow
growing up in a military family in
samarkand uzbekistan fuse emigrated to
Russia shortly before the fall of the
Soviet Union
his parents encouraged him and his
brother to embrace all that was Russian
so it wasn't until his late teens when
he learned to embrace his Uzbek heritage
fuze followed in his father's footsteps
and enrolled in the military showing an
aptitude for science in an early age the
military honed his interest in
mechanical engineering fuses applied
these skills and numerous engineering
projects which landed him a spot in the
coveted weapon testing debate at lb no
firing range near Moscow developing his
own weapon along with his ability to
improvise in the field with scrap
materials and minimal tools has made him
a legend among his fellow soldiers this
was one of the key reasons who became an
asset to Rambo operations during his
time in the twenty-seventh motor rifle
brigade he excelled his sharpshooter and
is extensive with the knowledge
deployment within Spitz Ness is
confirmed however all operation details
have remained classified fuses fluent in
boos Beck Russian Ukrainian and English
fuse was engaged for two years the call
off the wedding after who decided that
he want to follow a different path than
his life
he's an expert tinkerer in a master
craftsman he finds himself more at ease
when with mood machines rather than
other people his gruff demeanor and Curt
speech should not be mistaken for
bitterness he possesses strong moral
conviction to safe users restraint does
not fit the full picture other operators
prefer Doyle is mysterious but that's
not to say is difficult in fact is quite
pleasant in hospital just contained when
he does speak people tend to hang off
his every word field reports mention
that fuse really makes himself available
in team planning but often falls into a
cone of silence during operations fuses
past reports of recklessness in his eyes
his objective is to break down the
defenses efficiently as possible but
insisted to use a peerless while
hard-hitting fuse does possess good
situational awareness is clear that his
creative engineering skills are a
critical asset he is highly intelligent
and calculated those developed by fuse
and the experimental weaponry Brigade
the APM six was fuses attempt to create
a more powerful breach Church it proved
to be an effective means of clearing the
room dealing the most damage to hostiles
but keeping the operator relatively safe
it can be anchored either vertically or
horizontally once deployed the piston
burrows through the walls or floors
dispersing live cluster grenades while
spinning to deal the most damage from
all directions
the APM six is most useful in conditions
where collateral damage is not a concern
do you know what an artist and a sniper
have in common
details like when a touch of collar is
out of place when the shadow does not
match with its surroundings or when a
shape is not where it is supposed to be
the only difference is the stakes minor
higher teamer class cough code-named
glass is an attacking operator in team
rainbow his father worked in the
shipping industry and glares studied art
in secondary school in 2004 the deaths
that resulted from the dis LAN school
hostage crisis inspired him to transfer
to the Cadet Corps and pursue a career
and the Armed Forces afterwards
he attended the kerberos military
commanders training academy were a
developed world class partnership he
also really participated in cross-border
training exercises where he gained a
strong understanding of mandarin after
the academy he joined the ground forces
of the Russian Federation and later the
Spitz nos 45th guard regiment assigned
to special ops and VIP protection detail
reports consistently show that glass
possesses a unique creative approach to
problem-solving here's the squad member
with the most expertise in long-range
scope Brittany wore glasses and thrive
in large groups he's engaging in
expressive in one-on-one conversations
here's a patient temperament and can be
very reflective his background as an
artist his curiosity and his attention
to detail has trained him to be mindful
and process this mix glass an excellent
spotter and sniper
what stands out about glass this is what
it's surprising for so-and-so intensely
focused during operations glass
possesses many traits expected of a
highly trained marksman and field
reports demonstrate his knack for
improvising in tough situations
his ability to deconstruct complex
concepts on the fly
likely comes from his artistic side his
paintings are vibrant and expressive
they are more than an escape there are
spiritual cleansing or a depiction of
how he perceives suffering glass is well
respected by his team his humor and
observational skills make intolerant of
personality extremes the mark on his
right eye a scar is from whipping kick
although it's obvious that this isn't
the whole story the HDS flip site was
developed by the Spitz nests for Russian
snipers to use in tactical situations
with a range of targets may vary greatly
in the short amount of time the OTS o3
high-powered sniper weapon of glass
exceeds all previous Russian designs the
single point cut rifle barrel is the key
reason is weapon is so effective there
is no stress on the barrel and no wobble
on the drift so if you still miss it's
because you are glass even a precision
weapon as good as this isn't much used
without the HDS flip side the OTS o3 is
an integrated grail for mounting optics
or the tandem configuration allowing for
quick access to the HDS the thermal
detection is a point of pride and
contention among operator discussions
this weapon provides faultless technical
backup for someone with faultless skill
Reisen anthrax sarin gas Ebola VX gas
chimera viruses
some enemies are invisible but the CBR
and threat unit is rainbows shield
against those enemies that can kill you
with a single drop of blood nanobots
unlike the brother can even further
watch
[Music]
or one wrong breath Lera mell Canova
code-named finca is an attacking
operator and team member vinkor was nine
when she was diagnosed with neuropathy
that included the solute generation of
muscles and the loss of sensation in
limbs and extremities born three years
after the Chernobyl disaster in the
eradicated city of goo mal Belarus she
grew up around children already
suffering from birth defects her
diagnosis was the realization of their
fears so in appearance encouraged her
and her younger siblings to be
physically active she pushed herself
even harder determined to keep her body
in peak condition to wither the
neuropathy all three Malkin of children
grew up playing sports with finger
excelling those that require agility and
finesse but there was always the
knowledge that the neuropathy would
worsen and this son found a more
permanent solution she decided that that
someone was herself venca moved to
nervous abyss to study at the state
university and graduated with a PhD in
microbiology and immunology she remained
at NSU in the biotechnology and biology
laboratory her research uncovering
treatments for a variety of pathogens
and neuropathies including her own
through drugs and self dissolving
entities while she hadn't found a cure
she'd found her admission finger might
have stayed in the academic field had
she not received a visit from the
Federal Security Service of the Russian
Federation as Russian Spetsnaz operators
fest an ever growing danger of exposure
to hazardous materials for the first
time in her life
finca began thinking outside of her own
concerns her research had saved the
lives of perfect strangers and now they
were reaching out to her sending
grateful postcards and photos and
letters she could have a greater impact
still finger jumped at the chance to
work with Spitz News volunteers in a
variety of conditions she adapted the
nanobots to their high-performance
physiologies
quickly she became to enjoy the sense of
competition from rotary and the mental
toughness of the Russian Special Forces
members she joined the army with an eye
on becoming a red beret herself on the
front line saving lives is a chemical
biological radiological nuclear
specialist serving in the Russian army
finca rapidly proved herself physically
and mentally tough enough to try it for
the Spetsnaz it was a brutal course
culminating and close-quarter knife
battle training with Capcom a missed it
and a flourish from cup Karn opened up
her face from burrata cheek finger went
for a series of bone breaking punches to
his nose and ribs before the pain
overwhelmed they spent the night in the
mid tent neither of them speaking but
enjoying a new unspoken respect between
them from that day forward she earned
her name finca or knife
[Music]
finger became the spit snez CBRN
specialist joining the vinpearl unit
using the nanobots to help her unit
survive hot zones she was one of the
only people capable of tailoring the
nanobots to specific operators who work
in restructuring Russian battlefield
protocols in the handling and
neutralization of dangerous payloads and
who notice and she became the go-to
expert when it came to joint exercises
with other CTU's sips invited finger to
help her in POSIX put together a co VN
unit of the right lion was a first
choice venca discovered her neuropathy
was slowly growing resistant to
treatment the old fears returned every
akin pain analyzed and scrutinized as
she pushed herself even harder to peak
performance now she constantly tweaks
and modifies a formula to stave off
twitches and numbness that she mentioned
might be the onset of decline she pushes
herself to the point of throwing up
after workouts with IQ in Valkyrie
unable to distinguish between the
disease and normal fatigue is driven by
her fears and has made excellent by them
at the same time she is trying to find a
new treatment while keeping it a secret
the doc knows and is closely monitoring
her CMT in case it begins to affect her
performance she has not shared this with
anyone else not cup Khan who is a
no-nonsense mentor and not to chunker
with whom she drinks and flirts finger
delivers a nanobot shot to each operator
before an operation the Nana T's are
made up of zinc with the farm illogical
cocktail laced into the nanobots
construction when she activates her
signal the nanobots disintegrate with
the sync being treated as a nutrient by
the body and facilitating the absorption
of the drugs the operators receive a
boost of health to get him back on their
feet to give them an extra push and to
steady the rain
my last couple know pretty much all of
my seat videos have had a number of
errors in them particularly with the
operator cuts I think I've probably been
rushing them a little bit so hopefully I
managed to get this one right
or at least more right than the last
view also the SAS video was my first law
video for the game I've since learned a
lot more so at some point I'll be
remaking this video because I've left
out a lot of good Intel I'm reasonably
new to seach drawn in by the need for a
decent PvP experience and geez there is
a steep learning curve but regardless of
what some of you are saying in the
comments I'm not stopping anytime soon
because I'm thoroughly enjoying it
anyway I hope you've enjoyed this video
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one Cheers
[Music]